[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale paris-nice la course
au soleil passe par les yvelines pour la
dixième année consécutive c'est parti
pour le sommaire retour sur la première
étape de ce paris nice 2010 9 à saint
germain en laye l'étape longue de 130
8,5 km dans le département qui a vu le
néerlandais dylan groningen s'imposer
sur le fil devant le château
vous entendrez à toutes les réactions
coup de projecteur également sur les
bréviaires un village de 1300 habitants
et ville départ de la deuxième étape de
ce paris nice une grande première pour
la commune et à la fin de ce magazine
zoom sur l'essentiel de l'actualité
sportive dans le département résultats
et agenda à suivre prendre
[Musique]
oh
à
le départ sera donné dans quelques
minutes depuis saint germain en laye
arnaud péricard vous êtes le maire j
music vous êtes un maire très fier
aujourd'hui d'accueillir cette course au
soleil
alors on est très fier on est très
honoré évidemment on voulait être à la
hauteur et depuis aulas hier on a eu
dans le parc du château des animations
exceptionnelles énormément de monde
énormément d'enfants hier on avait voulu
effectivement activés autour de la
jeunesse des mobilités douces du vélo
même si on dit au graphique un peu
compliqué à saint germain avec quelques
collines on est une ville de vélo pour
ça apporte du dynamisme à une commune
courses comme paris-nice oui ça génère
de l'attractivité économique
ce sont des chambres d'hôtel qui sont
prises les gens vont dans les
restaurants non ça fait venir du monde
pierre j'ai vu énormément de monde qui
venait de dire de l'ensemble de l'île de
france mais beaucoup du val d'oise de
l'essonne des yvelinois en nombre on a
fait une course cyclo hier on avait
quasiment 1000 participants je crois que
c'est du jamais vu depuis dix ans et
tous les clubs cyclos dérive ils étaient
présents au gurten c'est la deuxième
fois depuis 2013 que la ville organise
un paris-nice est ce que la ville
s'inscrit dans cette histoire du paris
nice
alors ça s'inscrit dans l'histoire du
paris nice à s'inscrit dans l'histoire
cycliste française la fameuse course
paris-brest qu'a donné le nom au gâteau
paris-brest ensuite avant faisait un
arrêt à saint germain le tour de france
est venu plusieurs fois
la dernière fois c'était en 1978
donc ça nous donne des idées pour la
suite il ya beaucoup de monde aussi
aujourd'hui on voit ya énormément de
supporters juste derrière nous est ce
que ça vous fait plaisir justement qui
ait autant de monde pour une course si
populaire bon alors écoutez c'est une
course populaire
on a des vendéens on a les bretons on a
des espagnols on a des anglais beaucoup
à une forte communauté anglo saxon ici
qui vient supporter ses équipes et c'est
et ses coureurs
moi ça me fait énormément plaisir saint
germain c'est une ville qui bouge
et c'est une île qui n'est jamais aussi
belle que quand il ya de l'activité sera
l'arrivée vous allez décrié à l'arrivée
on se regarde l'arrivée on créera avec
tout le monde bien sûr avant le départ
plusieurs centaines de supporters se
sont réunis devant le château de saint
germain en laye pour voir la
présentation des coureurs
on pouvait notamment apercevoir de
nombreux heavy noir c'est chouette on
voit les couloirs de près voilà on est
là pour les encourager et puis c'est une
belle course qui s'annonce c'est une
course assez importante parce que y'a
les y aider qu'au pouvoir il ya des
grands enjeux aussi il n'y a pas que des
supporters français ici à paris nice il
ya également des supporters colombien je
suis un côté de martha martha pourquoi
vous êtes venus ici
et parce que je suis très très faim
della vela et supporter les colombiennes
les escales à voir aussi vous êtes venu
à combien du coup vous êtes 3 c'est ça
oui on ne sont pas seulement et qu'est
ce que vous allez faire du goût est bon
aujourd'hui on va supporter les
colombiens on va pris des photos s'ils
ont pu faire des signatures aussi
vous allez faire beaucoup de bruit et
oui aussi
ce portable est quand même bien
accueilli très très fort est-ce que vous
avez un petit champ à nous proposer
en tout cas les supporters colombiens
sont en surexcités dans le parc de saint
germain en laye ses supporters venus du
monde entier ont pu observer les 23
équipes et les 161 coureurs inscrits
pour cette édition 2010 9 un certain
thomas voeckler plusieurs fois maillot
jaune sur le tour de france est prêté au
jeu des pronostics juste avant le départ
aujourd'hui je suis un peu embêté parce
que avec les conditions météo très
honnêtement le scénario va être assez
incertain donc aller si je devais me
lancer j'aimerais veut dire le côté
franchouillard le même que l'an dernier
qui avait gagné la première étape de
paris-nice arnaud démare parce que c'est
là il est il a une belle équipe il est
bien entouré donc je peux dire lui mais
honnêtement aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
de vent aujourd'hui 1 ce dimanche à
saint germain en laye et même dans toute
les yvelines qu'est ce que ça fait quand
il ya autant de vent sur un parcours du
stress mais faut bien que le public
comprenne que le levant ça c'est
quasiment plus dur que des montagnes
dans le vélo parce que l'on peut pas
tout calculer il ya des gros risques de
chute il ya des stratégies d' équipe qui
se met en place sa joue énormément des
coudes
donc ça change complètement la course
c'est ce fort vent aujourd'hui et ça va
il y aura du gros gros spectacle
aujourd'hui
et quelle est la bonne stratégie
justement adopté le collectif
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le collectif
qui peut qui va primer si on n'est pas
doté d'un fort collectif c'est très
difficile de s'en sortir
faux le seul moyen c'est d'être malin il
peut y avoir des coureurs malins qui
arrivent à se placer mais même s'ils
n'ont pas une équipe totalement leurs
services
parmi les coureurs présents des
cyclistes locaux et notamment le cours à
versailles et de 30 ans kévin réza somme
et r6 mais sans les nommer aux
entraînements donc sans forcément signer
devant dans les amis la famille donc
voilà une bonne journée t'as pas mal de
vent aujourd'hui mais on fera avec et
quelques minutes plus tard c'est l'autre
local de l'étape tony gallopin habitants
de la vallée de chevreuse qui s'est
présenté devant le public
j'habite pas très loin demain encore
plus à la maison donc ouais c'est c'est
toujours spécial
c'est un beau tracé c'est à la maison il
ya du vent ça va être signée ça va être
dangereux
typiquement parisien toujours l'un des
favoris du jour n'est pas un ni vinoy
mais un cycliste originaire de l'oise
arnaud démare double vainqueur de la
première étape du paris nice sur les
deux dernières éditions
les habitudes ont fait que j'ai gagné
nombreuses voix donc
voilà aujourd'hui c'est une journée très
spéciale ya vraiment beaucoup de ventes
j'aime ça l'équipe aime ça donc on va
voir comment ça va se passer
plutôt confiance j'ai encore pris le
départ mais ça courait après au bout de
quelques kilomètres on va vite prendre
le vent de travers et 11h30 le départ
fictif est donné sur la place charles de
gaulle
[Musique]
en attendant le retour des cours à saint
jean brault les divers stands et est
ouvert au public
le paris nice est aussi occasion pour le
département de promouvoir le cyclisme
sur son territoire ici un stand ait
installé à saint germain en laye et bien
sûr je n'ai pas pu résister à l'idée de
me lancer sur ces jeux
[Musique]
ça conforte l'image de départements de
vie qui aime relever le vélo mais le
vélo sportif qui est la vitrine mais
aussi le vélo déplacements quotidiens
le vélo tous les cycles loisirs
bien-être
enfin je crois que entre saint quentin
et le championnat de france est
aujourd'hui paris nice depuis dix ans le
département prouve qu'il aime le vélo et
les infrastructures qui vont avec
puisque ce sont près de 600 km ok de
voies cyclables quand initié par pierre
bédier le département
après un peu plus de trois heures de
pause dans le département des yvelines
et sans 38,5 km c'est le néerlandais
dylan à grenoble et gan qui s'impose sur
le fil devant calais d wade fabio
jakobsen
c'était très plaisant de gagner
aujourd'hui aussi d'obtenir le maillot
jaune ce sera sympa de le porter ce
maillot jaune demain aujourd'hui c'était
une étape très dure avec beaucoup de
vent mais l'équipe a fait du très bon
travail avec est six coureurs dans le
premier groupe avec un point nous
restons devant donc c'est très bien pour
l'équipe et pour moi d'avoir gagné
aujourd'hui vous m'ayez dates suivantes
la pression preud'homme quelle est votre
réaction après cette première étape du
paris-nice 2019 une très belle première
étape marquée par le vent beaucoup
devant arriver ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon cycliste des bordures non sous
l'effet du vent de côté le peloton qui
se scinde en plusieurs veaux c'était
très beau à voir
ça donnait une course très intéressante
avec un sprint massif mais moins massive
qu'on ne pouvait l'imaginer
puisqu'il ya neuf et donc beaucoup de
vent et que c'est le jeune néerlandais
de wengen
double vainqueur d'étape sur le dernier
tour de france et gagner sur les champs
elysées et champs elysées d'aujourd'hui
c'était saint germain en laye face au
château donc une autre arrivée
absolument magnifique et il a triomphé
d'un rien devant un tout jeune
australien qui allait me one avec une
première étape où on a vu beaucoup d
favori de paris-nice français romain
bardet je pense coulommiers kinta d'or
aux premières loges parce qu'il fallait
se méfier évidemment des pièges de cette
première étape du couvent il vous plait
ce vainqueur
bien sûr qu'il me plaît puisque c'est
vraiment là il ya un plateau et un
plateau global formidable sur paris-nice
et il ya un plateau de sprinteurs
particulièrement alléchant et là c'est
clairement la nouvelle génération qui
gagne avec gros de wengen devant et wan
et jacobsen c'est à dire trois coureurs
qui sont qui sent qu'ils sont jeunes et
qu'ils vont certainement marqué le
sprint dans les années qui viennent et
la météo a fait bien sûr jouer les
trouble-fête a aujourd'hui le vent c'est
clair que c'est un élément qui donne une
course incertaine donc
dans la course a été très bien et puis
on avait le soleil pour finir sur cette
magnifique
arrivée finale là où est né louis xiv
quasiment avec le château en fond de
ligne
c'était magnifique merci christian
prudhomme et à demain un bréviaire avec
plaisir
[Musique]
deuxième jour de compétition bienvenue
aux bréviaire un village de 1300
habitants
[Musique]
pourquoi les brevets a parlé brevière
parce que c'est un endroit qui est bien
sympathique mais on a besoin de montrer
aussi aux coureurs au public les courses
de vélo peuvent s'organiser dans les
petits villages dans les grandes villes
bien évidemment mais aussi dans les
petits villages ont transporté champions
ici le l'élite du cyclisme mondial et
aujourd'hui aux premières plus petit
village de le départ de paris-nice donc
c'est pas rien ah oui c'est positif
regarder le monde qu'il ya autour et
tous les habitants je crois ont séché
leurs journées de travail pour pour être
ici les bréviaires et la dix septième
ville du département organiser un départ
du paris nice et c'est surtout une
grande première pour la commune
oui je suis très heureux quand le
président du département m'a proposé de
me recevoir cet événement on voyait que
la commune se lancer de l'honneur c'est
un grand honneur
18 ans mandat et puis un événement comme
ça c'est sûr la dernière année c'est
parfait voilà donc j'ai beaucoup
plaisanté avec la la commune des brevets
remis 300 habitants deux agents
techniques cinq barrières ndaw est c'est
pas mal présentés sur le sujet mais sut
satisfait que les bénévoles qu'on a
recrutés sur les côtés aujourd'hui on
réussit à la préparation nord pour cette
course
les camions viennent d'arriver le podium
est monté ce que vous arrivez quand même
à reconnaître votre village non c'est
vrai que depuis hier soir
tout est transformé les 270 barrière il
a fallu les allonger la foulée les
préparez donc et puis à
la voirie les les arrêtés municipaux
pour interdire la circulation prévenir
la population
je vous garantis que la pression est
montée pendant pendant ces jours ci puis
grâce à mon premier adjoint jacques
frantic je peux citer donc à ces deux
rives et toute une équipe pour qu'on
réussisse cette matinée merci beaucoup
je vous laisse profiter du spectacle
merci à vous quelques heures avant le
départ les bus des équipes cyclistes se
sont installés à proximité du centre
village de nombreux supporters se sont
réunis autour des véhicules et notamment
de celui de l'une des équipes phares du
paris-nice 2019
ag2r la mondiale équipe de romain bardet
des tony gallopin c'est une équipe
france ne nous connaît mal les coureurs
c'est pour nous c'est sensationnel quand
on découvre tous les hauts niveaux des
vélos le nouveau matériel et tous
on se dit on
c'est pourquoi on voit beaucoup à la
télévision mais en public c'est quand
même le pur quand on aime le vélo ben on
adore ses supporters ont également pu
observer la préparation des vélos juste
avant le départ c'est le travail de
mickaël szkolnik qui est dans l'équipe
ag2r la mondiale depuis cinq ans
l'expert peut passer plusieurs heures
sur la préparation d'un vélo après une
étape
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on en est là vont
lui l'on vérifie toutes les coupes des
serrages et et après c'est le coureur
qui va choisir les braquer qui eux et
les auteurs d'euros qui veut et donc on
fait là un des lois la demande en
matière et est donc une fois que tout
est assemblé tout est réglé le vélo est
prêt et opérationnel pour la journée
quand on est passionné de vélo de belles
mécaniques ses dents de scie que du haut
de gamme donc donc c'est plus
passionnant que tu as une fois leur vélo
près direction la présentation
officielle devant le spectateur les
coureurs se sont ensuite installés sur
la ligne de départ pour cette étape 263
5 km jusqu'à bellegarde dans le loiret
les sportives ont encore parcours et
41,5 km dans le département avant de le
quitter à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et
là encore les conditions climatiques
sont difficiles
alors on va partir après dans la plaine
donc là un peu au départ il ya un peu de
forêt si mes souvenirs sont bons mais
dès qu'on va sortir de la forêt il
risque d'y avoir beaucoup de vent et
quand on regarde comment sont les
drapeaux je pense que ça va aller très
très vite une qualité la stratégie pour
lutter contre le vent ne s'est pas
lutter faut faire avec
parce que quand on quand on roule il
faut savoir comment monter des bordures
d un éventail ce qu'on appelle un
éventail et puis essayer d'éjecter le
maximum de coureurs arrivent avec vous
le départ fictif a été donné
officiellement à 12h40 devant la mairie
devant plus d'un millier de spectateurs
[Applaudissements]
le paris-nice reviendra l'année
prochaine dans les yvelines dans le
cadre de son partenariat avec le
département la course au soleil fêtera
en 2020 sa 78ème édition
tout un symbole
[Musique]
on commence cette page résultats par du
football dans le championnat de d1
district plaisir s'est incliné 3-2 sur
la pelouse d'un dricourt maurepas n'a pu
faire mieux que match nul 1 but partout
montées sont certes imposés 2 à 1 chez
lui face à marly le roi enfin carrière
grésillons tel et chercher une précieuse
victoire sur le terrain du fc mantois au
classement sartrouville qui n'a pas joué
ce week-end reste leader avec 25 points
on joue également sur les terrains de
rugby ce week-end dans le championnat de
fédérale 2 contre-performances pur
plaisir
les hommes de sébastien roncalli se sont
inclinés sur le fil 18 à 17 à domicile
contre chartres
une défaite qui pourrait avoir de
lourdes conséquences au classement les
plaisirs oies sont à l'heure actuelle 9e
sur 12 équipes engagées et ne compte que
trois petits points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable
en basket trap est toujours en course
pour la montée les trappistes se sont
largement imposés sur le terrain de
saint laurent de la plaine 96 à 75 pour
le compte de la 18e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 un résultat
qui leur permet d'être à trois points du
leader à quatre matches de la fin de la
saison
enfin un dernier résultat de basket en
nationale 3 l'équipe féminine du chesnay
versailles s'est imposé à domicile
contre le club basket dif
score final 62 à 51 lui lcv 78 reste
premier du championnat avec seulement
une défaite au compteur depuis le début
de la saison il devrait se qualifier
pour les play-offs de fin de saison
[Musique]
on commence à ta gens d'à part de la
course à pied la 12e édition de l'eco
trail est organisée ce samedi 16 mars
les participants du 80 km partiront de
l'île de loisirs de 50 ans divine pour
rejoindre la tour eiffel
au programme également des courses de 18
30 et 45 km plus de douze mille
participants sont attendus pour
participer à cette épreuve devenue une
tradition dans les yvelines
on écoute fabien parmentier un coin
originaire de montigny le bretonneux qui
a déjà participé à onze éditions du 80
km de l'eco-trail pour entrer dans la
course où trouver le bon rythme faut
éviter de passes faire d'entorse parce
qu'effectivement on part sur la base de
loisirs de saint quentin et puis on part
dans un une espèce de chant qui est
relativement beau ce n'est pas évident
pour les chiffres il faut faire faut
rester attentif aux trouver le bon
rythme parce se cramer trop vite
il y aura du foot us ce week-end les
moins de 19 ans des templiers
d'elancourt reçoivent les conquérants de
caen en complexe sportif europe
la rencontre est programmée à 18h les
templiers doivent l'emporter pour
conserver la première place du
classement
en rugby un match décisif dans le
championnat honneur versailles ra défier
ce dimanche là ni pour le compte de la
15e journée du championnat
une victoire et les versailles et
devrait officiellement terminé premiers
de leur poule une place qui les
propulserait directement en fédérale 3
si vous voulez les soutenir le match se
jouera au parc municipal des sports à
lagny toujours en rugby est toujours
dans le championnat de division honneur
le sky rublee reçoit ce dimanche à 15
heures le seo multisports bagneux un
match de milieu de tableau entre le sky
7e et le cinquième
la rencontre sera programmé au stade du
bout des clous et on termine par un mot
de baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux débuteront leur saison les
dimanches 24 mars à 11h lésigny montrent
un front chaud ronis dans leur stade de
jean maréchal pour cette première
journée de d1 le staff pourra compter
sur ses trois nouvelles recrues
sylvain perrin formé à chartres et
ancien joueur des barracuda de
montpellier raphaël gimenez un champ
extérieur d'origine dominicaine et
francisco perez un autre 2 min 15 /
michiko les trois joueurs devraient
débuter le 24 mars prochain
c'est la fin de cette émission spéciale
paris nice à bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures sportives sur tv à 78
[Musique]